hey gang real quick before we get the
old show started let's talk about these
live days we got coming up
it's the keep it moving 2021 tour
and we're coming to a town near you
we're going to be
in atlantic city new jersey june 18th oh
yeah and then we're gonna be in chicago
for our fourth and final show on june
22nd
then we're heading over to indianapolis
indiana
at the helium over there on june 23rd
get some tickets
and then we're coming back thursday
night back to the windy city
for two sold out shows so if you heard a
date on there
that wasn't sold out buy some tickets
and come see us
it's gonna be a great time yeah guys the
live show's awesome it's stand up and
then we play ayg
with the audience we answer your
questions it's a good [ __ ] time get
involved
see you there oh baby welcome to another
exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast
this is r u garbage sure is it's a
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find if they
grow up to be classy or if they're just
a big old piece of trash
i'm your host dave foley coming at you
on a beautiful day
down here at aunt toddy's basement it's
a family episode
i'm feeling good she's out of town for
the weekend
where's she at she's down to shore man
memorial day she's their problem
yeah she's down to shore that's [ __ ]
she's she's north wildwood pd's probably
yeah she's out of our hair yeah
let her stay down there for the summer
i'm fine with it get a job at flanders
or something i don't know whatever the
kids do down there
pumping uh custard sure it's good stuff
uh sitting directly across from me from
the miami office
from ayg south baby
who's the new floor manager at
fuddruckers this guy's a real pain in
the ass
i feel like i work at kahunaville this
guy's a real stickler make sure you do
your silver
it's my cabana where i stopped by rudy's
you look like you're gonna go bowling in
the bahamas
toby you do your side work
this guy's this new guy's cracking down
look out
yeah ladies and gentlemen this man goes
by many names
bozo but around this time it's gonna be
one of those episodes
around this time around paycheck time
you really butter me up we all referred
him as mr ryan
all right kevin james everybody the jigs
up the [ __ ] account's empty we're
screwed we're tanking
a couple of [ __ ] suppliers that have
paid things went belly up yeah for a
little inside baseball we're getting
banged over the head right now
talking about coming anybody got 20
bucks i can borrow to make it through
the weekend
hey patty that necklace is going back
[Laughter]
maybe catch you at halloween or
something oh god hey what's up gang
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you rate review subscribe on
itunes full video available on youtube
and as you know those numbers are
true not a fan
not a fan of not that at all i like it
traditional
true to roof that's the kind of guy i am
right up the middle okay
no no bells and whistles way to yes
ended so far in the first [ __ ] 90
seconds you jerk off
i just sat here and let you [ __ ] on my
shirt for [ __ ] 45 seconds
you can't roll with the [ __ ] with the
roof god damn it
uh and then also patreon.com you can
sign up you get bonus episodes of ayg
you can get episodes of hard feelings
which uh if you're not familiar it's me
and foley
uh behind the curtain a little bit
behind the curtain it's a lot of
somebody said it's like uh you guys do
festivus every
week it's the airing of grievances the
airing of the grievances whatever's been
[ __ ] hard
feeling if i've been bothering fully i
hear it if he's been bothering me he
hears
it it's a whole it's a [ __ ] it's like
an hr meeting or if the world's just
getting you down whatever it is could be
traffic could be anything
it's not all hugs and kisses over there
yeah patreon's cooking shout out to
everybody on the [ __ ] patreon we love
everybody if you ever subscribed
to [ __ ] itunes youtube we appreciate
it all thank you so much
yes we love you guys very much quick
shout out to our producer extraordinaire
the magic man
the t-bone mcmuffin he he hangs with the
homies a lot
the homies and we we [ __ ] on the homies
how we met the homies met the homies
[ __ ] salt of the earth people i'm
telling you right now
love the [ __ ] homies love this guy
t-bone
everybody loves you what's up people
mcmuffin toby mcmullen everybody hey
i didn't know what to do on that intro
you said my name about 15 times this
host today is a real cowboy i got to
tell you
yeah i'll tell you if you hear about a
party in arizona in two days i got the
crew for you
yeah yeah t-bone i met t-bone's buddies
they're nice but did you meet the
extended version of what i saw
i met the twins i met the twins and
they're exact if you made me
if you made me close my eyes and
describe t-bone's friends it's these two
[ __ ] kids
long hair high as a kite two skateboards
[ __ ]
haven't had it not identical maternal
twins
different moms
i swear to god those two would be the
first
they were they were a cast of characters
yeah but great dudes shout out to the
homies shout out to the homies
big shout out big shout out all the
homies left today
door closed i've been keeping it
together i had a big weep on the couch
nice yeah got a long rainy weekend ahead
of you
ain't no sunshine and rainbows so that
should do good for you you got some
playstation some domino's money
huh yeah some razor blades some rat
poison
a couple of revolvers how would you i'd
go out and get like three or four
outfits for the cat and start taking
pictures
[Laughter]
here's mr mittens in a raincoat his name
is a little stank and he'll put some
respect on his name
oh my god gang it's a [ __ ] family
episode it's me and the kip kipparino
here
uh do you want to i'd listen you know i
i joke
i think you're a fashionable guy thanks
pal i like what you're doing this
this seems this isn't the guy i know
it's a bold kippy i gotta be honest
so i bought it i know wouldn't walk
around and that's not even
that's like what these kids this is
that's not an uncle hank
no this is a cool shirt this is a cool
shirt it's from zara make a couple bucks
i'm sorry
i'm no longer h m i've upgraded to zara
zara's in the [ __ ] hawaiian shirt
game i didn't know that these are big
everyone's doing these issues it's big i
i you feel like a ball i'm walking on
the street i pass nine people with like
a similar shirt oh so
it is what it is are you gonna switch to
red stripe
that's why i like dx i'm the most
interesting kippy in the world
i don't always shop at zara but when i
do i look like a double xl
that's a large um dozen button that's
why i like dxl
everything's one of a kind only made one
kippy's ready to pick up some dusty
muffin the shuffleboard course oh yeah
we'll be all over that shuffleboard
court
and all that belle del boca vista um i
uh i bought it um
and i wore it to uh i wore it this past
weekend to a
barbecue and i got wow my friends are
sad like i
like you know well we we're i'm from
above just the look you showed up in
with it open
open i think you're like an fbi wire man
yeah
you look like you should be in a van
right yeah i'm fine with it
um you're backing up donnie brosco
somewhere
look at the bond hey donnie what's
forget about me
that's on paul giamani i got a cold beer
on my head
[ __ ] it about it oh [ __ ] of the bud
now is johnny black the same as johnny
retinol
um you stink with a ham sandwich look at
your
brown paper bag um and i was real
nervous i take heat
no i thought i walked in i'm like i did
i was ready to just [ __ ]
i thought it was going to be pink mist
the second i opened the door just to
head shop
but uh we're sitting there we're out
front smoking and someone goes yo dope
shirt and i'm like and then i really
yeah it's cool and i'm like
oh wow dude it was like a it was like a
pep talk to get out of there it's just
not you
i know well it is now baby
[Laughter]
is coming in hot i don't know that's a
good thing or not i don't know if this
is you
i don't know if this is you turn because
because it has a it has
i'm about to be on the run in south
america kind of vibe to it it's it is
what it is baby we're figuring it out
dated that you could have a suitcase
oligo in a private plane somewhere oh
you're trying to hang out
by the way foley was sending us [ __ ]
private
planes on craigslist 222 thousand we can
get a cessna
you got it you literally just told me of
300 in your bank account
you're [ __ ] shopping for private yeah
his accounts payable screwing us at the
end of the month
[ __ ] jammed up over here you gotta
keep that river so i told you
so everybody knows now everybody expects
also the plane was from 1976.
you probably have kept it yeah so is
that antique yeah i'll take it
zara baby 34.99 is pretty good nice i
can't really argue with that ah i'm
stepping my game up
you know but the fact that everybody's
doing it is trash i noticed that
sorry to annoy me i guess i got to
figure my situation out yeah
i'm not used to you and black you look
like the evil foley
you look like you you you you look like
you killed the [ __ ] hawaiian chair
foley
and this is it you look like you're
about to screw you look like a bad guy
in a movie so he's the funny guy huh
yeah
yeah
yeah you look evil you don't look yeah
black isn't
isn't fitting for you i like black i'm
all black
you're the only guy black isn't slimming
on
it's an eclipse super moon last night
and then a lunar eclipse strange vibes
out there
gotta watch out maybe that's why you're
wearing this whack-a-doo shirt
i bought it a week you guys doesn't
explain anything
i'm living my best life wait till you
see my new shorts oh you don't you're
not wearing it i got the i got the euro
cut bathing suit for a while
what oh yeah my [ __ ] hoagie crusher
[Laughter]
this guy walking around with two
racquetballs i gotta
kind of roll a quarters in the front
wait a minute um i'm
kidding i'm kidding
we had a really cool now i would uh
what's that shirt made out of
what's the fabric terry not terry cloth
um linen
there's no lin there's no linen pants
coming right
i've i've perused the matching little
[ __ ]
frame over here in san juan yeah we're
not there yet buddy
you're still climbing through the sewer
whatever
i've been trying to get this guy
successful for a decade he just got his
heels plugged in the same you better put
your saint martin wear away for a little
while i was just
i was just looking up [ __ ] trips to
the saints and you're yelling at me for
looking at planes
how are you going to get down there how
are you going to get down here kippy
it's like [ __ ] it's better than dragging
me to the airport all the time we can
get a private plane for 300 grand right
now that's 300 grand you only gotta put
down ten percent
come up with that in a couple of minutes
i found out my step dad's been watching
plane repo
where they re like you can fight you
obviously finance those planes
you got a lot of loads that's what i'm
saying we can finance it we'll get some
old drunk to fly it
we do we're barely covering rent a
couple of birds to play hostess
or whatever it is you both just canceled
your memorial day weekend
see today's runs today's runs like a
well-oiled
tight enough to ship every once in a
while don't forget where you came from
you know what i mean usually that's when
you
when you're looking at your [ __ ] navy
federal account and you're coming up red
dude i had it below deck i don't know
what's going on but i had a negative
bounce on paypal today
what the i don't know how i owed them
1467.
i was first time i ever saw it i opened
it up and it said red negative 1467.
and i was like it's linked to my cards
in my bank account
i don't know we gotta get giuliani in
here
fudge these numbers i don't know what's
going on but toady runs like a well owed
machine unless
if somebody doesn't play ball then it's
the [ __ ] house of cards crumbles
toby's legit scared for the future nah
you'll be all right
we'll find you a good home i'm chilling
i don't spend my money yeah either do i
i take this shirt off i have the exact
one under it
ah we're having a [ __ ] good job
having a good show in the real trash
colors that's a cameo app
you can i know we put an end to the
cameo but we went up
might have to dust it off in these next
couple of days got a birthday coming up
it's graduation season we'll come to the
party yeah
100 bucks you get me and foley and i
need a sixer
i love a nice high school graduation
party always [ __ ] top shelf
nice that's when you always found out
whose parents were trashy yeah
that's when you first started the sun
went down
oh man the sun went down at a high
school grad party the [ __ ] wackos
came out
that are they letting the kids drink not
letting the kids drink drink
so it was like there was a handful of
parties you knew you could booze at
right my house was one
of it was also like don't celebrate it
let like the grandparents and somebody
aunts and uncles like let the
you know let the bozos thin out a bit
and then when it's the crew you know 20
30 people hang in the backyard
you know we can we can booze it up a
little bit went to this one girls party
uh right away you get there it's like
they hand you a beer you know what i
mean
they're not asking who's driving who's
doing nothing yeah usually the classier
ones the food is kind of presented first
yeah yeah mom or maybe you know what's a
good
sign is if they're doing like high-end
cocktails [ __ ] i mean when they're
throwing out like a batch of apple
martinis
there's a shaker or something like that
that's nice yeah but we were at this
solo cup in a half warm beer yeah that
may or may not have a ping-pong ball in
it
my buddy pat got so drunk at this party
it was still daytime and the grandmother
was still there and he threw meatballs
in the pool
and meatballs was disgusting i mean
meatballs as a dog meatballs
[Laughter]
so i remember this this girl's dad
they were like someone was like yo where
can we smoke weed or something
and he's like what you're wearing a tank
top dude if you're a dad wearing a tank
top at a grab party
it's a tough look okay put some [ __ ]
sleeves on
your baby your baby girl just walked
down the aisle in the aisle
you're definitely not a sunscreen man so
you're burnt oh yeah he was
he was like oh yeah he was he was he was
brown he was just
oven mitt on one hand for the grill yeah
yeah yeah yeah
no apron this guy going and he's or if
he does have an apron it's got did you
lift it up he's got that big dong on it
jefferson
oh my god did i see one my uncle broke
one of one of those out of me when i was
like
he like had at the party he's like oh
look at this and i thought
i was like [ __ ] eight i was like is
that how big they're supposed to be
because i am this thing was like two and
a half feet i was like i'm way off if
that's the case i gotta go to the doctor
that would be like nothing
mom make an appointment yeah i'm [ __ ]
over
here i got something medically wrong
with it
i just thought it was the irish curse
man i fired a pediatrician will you
that's a tough look i did that would be
like a sex crime today
what [ __ ]
it was like 85 or something like that he
was just out there cooking and showed us
and it murdered
oh yeah killed it always killed cow you
can't be doing that these days that's
true
so we're at this girl's party
everybody's [ __ ]
bombed up i think there was like a
[ __ ] like an air
about an air bounce house or a bounce
house whatever high school
yeah that's the kind of people we i grew
up with [ __ ]
and he's going
he's like someone's like yo can we smoke
weed or something like he heard the
conversation he heard weed he's going
who's got weed and we're like remember
that song you know
beanie seagull smoked a la la la neptune
smoked you remember that it was like a
jay-z song oh yeah yeah yeah from back
in the day
i guess that was hot or whatever he
that's the one rap song he knew
and he's sitting there [ __ ] blitz
dude
wait he wasn't he wasn't asking who was
the weed to tell you does not do it he
was asking who's got it like someone
someone asked where's the weed and he
heard weed
okay i didn't know he was standing there
because he [ __ ] he smells like a bar
right this guy
and he's going i hope i don't get in
trouble for that and he's going
you can only smoke weed if you got a
bong bigger than mine and i'm like this
get me the [ __ ] out of here sir would
they be serving the cake too
where are the hors d'oeuvres and he's
going
is there a gift table anywhere i can put
this down say her say the girl's name
was courtney right his daughter's name
was courtney's going
courtney smokes the la la la and me and
my boys are like dude
[ __ ] steal the [ __ ] quarter keg
and let's get the [ __ ] out of here
she was getting railed freshman year oh
yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's a tough look
i'll trash you down at the graduation
party
you can't be wearing a tank top or jean
shorts to your parents out there
or kids if you're graduating and that's
what your parents are wearing you got to
do something no
you can't be the trashy house no a
classy house
the the house that stays there toby's
over that's gonna there's gonna be it's
gonna be popping this weekend
yeah yeah yeah do it right drink watch
drink once everybody leaves
sun goes down it's you're not being
afraid it's a normal party when the
family's there when the family leaves
your stock beers or whatever
throughout it then do you everybody
looks the other way yeah like a [ __ ]
gentleman yeah shotgun a beer in the
bathroom
like a gentleman i'm a shocking beer
this weekend
when the parents get too loose it's
never the kids it's always the parents
yeah well they don't party that much you
know what i mean
i guess well like they don't
i think they're going like oh we gotta
hang with the kids meanwhile i'm doing
this every [ __ ] third night you know
what i mean
my stamina in high school i was [ __ ]
cooking then these [ __ ] parents try
a couple of taquez's shots next thing
you know their panties are on their head
see i got the big man's number today no
you got the giggies
trying to [ __ ] go toe-to-toe so we
were at graduation parties that are like
parents fought kids kids for parents oh
yeah
i remember the first time i dude it was
a scene we talked about this but i i
remember the first time i saw an adult
punch
like legit fight a 15 year old kid yeah
yeah
yeah yeah we were calling this because
dude had longer hair calling him bon
jovi and he did not
it was like it was like a it was like a
cousin's
husband or something somebody excited
somebody's cousin no blood relation he
just came in
[ __ ] now doesn't know anybody at the
party and does not give
a [ __ ] yeah he dude he punched his kid
through like a [ __ ] stack of bushes
this kid [ __ ]
this kid ended up in the street he
appeared like homer
yeah that's always the mark of of
your circle and your family oh yeah good
old graduation
oh yeah if there's no pool tough luck
everybody's just sweating it out
like they're going through heroin out of
there but he's chained to a chair
sitting in those chairs sun beating down
the plastic [ __ ]
tablecloth the chips are all [ __ ]
stale by now because the air's been
getting at him
some old deviled eggs i think there's
some beans left
trash oh god good times though oh that's
funny
gang this podcast is sponsored by better
help
the folks at betterhelp want to know is
there something in your life that's
keeping you from your happiness
something that's holding you back a
better help can help
with a licensed professional therapist
assigned right to you
you can start communicating with them
under 48 hours it's not a crisis line
it's not a self-help line we're talking
about professional
counseling done securely online in the
privacy of your own home
services available to clients worldwide
yeah guys
if you're not familiar with talk therapy
it is a game changer it's been a game
changer for me
uh i started probably about five or six
years ago
and it's it really helps you out it it
makes you realize where you came from
where you're going
it you take inventor i can't stress it
enough especially if you're trying to
accomplish something big in your life or
you
you're at a tough time in your life talk
therapy can really help so check it out
uh better help want you to start living
a happier life today
you can visit their website and read the
testimonials that are posted there daily
by thousands of people but visit
betterhelp.com
garbage one more time that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p
and join over one million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional uh
in fact they're recruiting new
additional counselors in
all 50 states they're cooking over there
at better health yeah what i mean
uh special offer for our podcast
listeners uh you get 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
garbage one more time for you guys write
it down
betterhelp.com garbage gang let's take a
quick second to talk about one of our
favorite sponsors here on the podcast
who that phew
the fume inhaler it's absolutely
fantastic it's a canadian made wooden
inhaler with no electronics
and cores that's filled only with the
benefits of super
plants no chemicals at it nope they have
the nice cores that you stuff into the
beautiful little
the little inhaler that they have it's
all natural it's portable it's
portable it's great for allergy relief
um you know what they told the chemicals
to do
take a hike hit the brick gaze in them
nope nope kick rocks
nicotine replacement whatever you want
to do fits right in your pocket
you simply slide your favorite core into
your fume and breathe in the benefits of
mother
nature baby it's that simple check out
their variety of blends and their
benefits
at www.breathefume.com
and use code garbage garbage
for 10 off your order yeah guys uh if
you're not familiar they sent us they've
been sending us
a bunch of this stuff it's floating
around here fantastic uh
i used it to help uh the urge for
quitting cigs which you know everybody
if you're
if you're if you're smoking cigs you got
to stop at some point give fume a try
it's better than the inhalers and all
that all the nicotine inhalers and the
the vaping and stuff like that um also
they just sent they they got they
released something new
for allergies which i don't know if you
see the pollen you walk outside it looks
like a [ __ ] bee came brutal
it's horrible uh do they have things
like reassurance which are lavender
lemon cinnamon for calming stress relief
anti-inflammatory benefits bubbly lime
which is lime lemon and spearmint
for energy and mood boosting whatever
you're looking for they got it go check
it out on the website you can subscribe
for monthly deliveries
so you never run out of your fume
surprise supply so head to
breathefume.com that's b r e
a t h e fume f u m.com
and use promo code garbage the link will
be in the description to save 10
and breathing the benefits of world
super plants today
oh yeah all right good time guys as you
know on the old family yeps
uh when you join the patreon we'll
answer your garbage question on the air
it's just the best way to do it we get
uh so many submissions through dms and
emails
we just can't keep up so patreon uh when
you join the patreon we will answer your
question
and we'll get to everybody we do some
new ones some old ones you know keep it
fresh
you know what i mean some of you some of
your questions are like animal
i don't even think i can read this on
air if i can get [ __ ] i might get a
[ __ ]
it's like a misdemeanor or something i
have to pay a fine for some of these
things i can't take you seriously with
that shirt
well you better start because we got
another about 45 minutes left
he looks like robin williams and looks
like in good morning vietnam
he does though um yeah
all right thanks for that
i love it uh sure sure
sure what do you get let's see let's see
this one's just
nuts to me i don't this is from reed i
can't even understand this
ever pour an unfinished drink back in
the bottle
i guess if you pour a coke only like
from like a two liter only drink half
and then pour it back in
i know exactly what the gentleman's
talking about you do that you've never
not finished a drink though this is
that's nuts to me
you pour it you pour a [ __ ] 12 ounce
glass of something and you can't finish
it
that's you don't you're not a guy who
doesn't drink [ __ ] his
a half a soda in recent no usually i
i pound it i pound everything just
whatever it is so no in recent years i'd
have to say no
but i do remember pouring something back
into a bottle
oh wine oh yeah my mom a couple weeks
ago
we bought a nice bottle of wine it's bad
if you're doing it to a nice bottle
i'd let you do sutter home or cavett
yeah she drink
we poured her glass and she didn't want
one so she poured it into the
bottle that's a little if she didn't
want it then the bottle disappeared
strangely enough yeah you probably
walked with it
oh no that's trash yeah yeah i can't be
doing it that's a tough look i can't
even think of what you would do it with
i guess i might have combined oj or
somebody combined a ketchup bottle or
two or the syrup or something yeah i
mean come on that's what
that's what you [ __ ] do can't be
having two half opens floating around
no you should be able to finish a drink
that gets like my
my wife has like a one of those cups
it's like god keeps a
cup of coffee hot for 72 hours it's like
who the [ __ ] needs 72 hours to finish a
cup of coffee i don't get that
i've never been drinking something where
i'm like i need this cold
all day it lasts 15 seconds it's gone
yeah my uh my fear
is that there's a level of garbage out
there that we haven't even gotten to yet
like
and it's just starting to poke its head
up in comments and tweets
photographs of what people are eating
yeah what consider what's considered a
meal
it's like x-files like scully and mulder
well that one dude was doing like
[ __ ]
pop-off [ __ ] hot pockets the other
night on twitter
but had the uh the fortune cookie from
panda express
class up the meal no matter what is that
what you think it does
i think i think if you have any type of
dessert or
treat or a fortune cookie is not a
fortune cookie that came
from another takeout order on a previous
day is not dessert
but still they put they put the meal
together in a gentleman's way
the fortune was class to me you have gut
rot
yeah yeah you now have gout you're late
on your bills
um you will be late on your bills in the
future
this one's like a sophie's choice for us
a little bit because
we're garbage not that the new one i'm
sorry okay i've never
i've never saw the film so i never know
what that means
it's it's it's a it's a rock and a hard
place right yeah i think she has to
doesn't have to
she has to save someone but then someone
dies so is nicholson in that
no i think it's the you love me you
really really love me sally fields
maybe really sophie's choice i'll have
to check it out i
haven't had a little time this weekend
more fans fell through more of a beaches
kind of guy
oh don't get me started you know what i
was listening to on the way in here
kelly clarkson break away i don't know
that one choking me up you know kelly
clarkson i know kelly clarkson i don't
know break away her main hit
i'll spread my wings and i'll learn how
to fly
somebody it's like real sing-songy yeah
i know it that was like an old irish
song that's what it reminds her
and learned how to fly a little drunk
um all tanked up at a bar and like you
know the words of danny boy
[Music]
oh you ever been to a concert where you
didn't want to seem like you didn't know
the words so you're singing along but
you're not quite
right ah the last word
you're like the hype man been there
that's trash oh yeah
um all right this one this is a sophie's
this is
on one end i respect the hustle because
we're garbage
fair enough on the other end it directly
affects us financially so i don't know
what to do what
this is from ryan is there bad news is
it trash to share your patreon login
with someone else
i don't want to encourage it but i get
it sure
right and i think it's the right answers
to go like
i'll be like the parents at the
graduation party once the sun goes down
i've never
i wouldn't know where to send a check to
netflix
hbo max on top sending a check whatever
you don't have a checkbook they ain't
getting it anyway how do you pay your
rent every month
check whose is that mine okay just
checking
i used to pay my rent by leaving a stack
of cash in the bread box
and a different shady character when it
comes scooping up every month
jesus oh that's awesome
that is awesome it'll be in the bread
box
if he gives you any trouble go for the
gut i had a guy when we were at temple
he would hit you up a couple of days and
because he was hemmed up
i paid cash up until
six months ago really yeah
yeah that's trash shouldn't be paying
rent and cash it's a bad luck
it's over a thousand bucks that's tough
that's what i'm saying if it's like 500
i can respect that nah i was [ __ ]
counting and they weren't hundreds
either you were a [ __ ] 10 and 20s
kind of guy
[Laughter]
it was like you were in [ __ ] you know
bad boys too with the one who knows if
he's counting if he gets into fives
early that's not a good sign
it's probably not all there gotta take
the rest of the day off to count this
yeah what were you gonna say i forget um
paying cash yeah i forget what i was
going to say
cash is a bad cash for rent it's a tough
loan oh check
it's not your check is that a money
order no
yeah me either what are we doing over
here
atlantic city june 18th come on out to
the 8 30 show tickets are at it one show
we condensed it it's one big show we're
doing since things have changed so still
socially distance but one big show
fantastic
um yeah you know i'd appreciate it
if you i get a lot of money times are
tough not everybody's got cash
and also you're sharing you're spreading
we would be lying to say what like i
said i've never i've never i've been
watching netflix for over 10 years i've
never paid yeah but there's no
i don't when i watch netflix i don't
watch mr netflix
what do you mean oh you're not watching
him they're they're watching us
okay yeah but like i said after dark
just don't post it anywhere that's all i
care yeah i don't care if you share with
a friend
sure help spread the word everybody's
been hemmed up sure we're currently
hemmed up
currently send it to us yeah i mean hey
[ __ ] venmo me to five bucks
yeah sim can't be the come down page
um all right let's see here this
okay uh this is from willie william how
long have you lived with a slow
shower dream
i've lived in my parents house with a
slow
sink drain for 35 years
what are they doing over there i don't
know why you get on top of drano
did they do it comes and it goes and it
comes up and they don't know when the
guy comes
they've had the bathroom redone two or
three times
since i've been since we've been there
twice at least
still just [ __ ] drain everything nice
bathtub
nice bathroom nicer than i expected i
don't know what it is
you're talking about a family who their
toilet shits onto their lawn
yeah doesn't it happen to you in the
front it's a little bit of an issue with
the
plumbing downstairs i think these
goddamn kids putting these paper towels
and these butt wipes in in this in in
the in the toilet
how many times he tell you get out of
there
uh yeah that's i forgot you you guys
have plumbing issues all around it seems
yeah it's okay that makes more sense
really more patreon material but fair
i don't know how my father's gonna
appreciate this toby
tobias um i uh
you got like [ __ ] on your lawn i can cut
it
what do you care what are you getting
okay but i won't yeah we're not cutting
it
um i was just homeless past weekend
up until yesterday actually i think i
got home yesterday two days ago um
and the the shower i grew up in
i don't know what dude it's like you're
it's like you're wait you need a [ __ ]
set of waiters when you're taking a
shower
i'm not about that either it's like all
door and i'm like what are we i feel
like
i feel like i'm going to get a [ __ ]
stung by an eel yeah
there are crabs in here yeah when we get
mud bugs
i don't like it's weird but it's also
like i get it the broad's old now and
it's the secondary showers they got
their shower
sure no and she just does bass for the
kids now yeah they're not taking showers
no
but it's like i'm like what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] there's light bulbs in those
rooms oh dude it gets
barren in some of them some parts of
that house yeah um
looks like a sample home but also we got
[ __ ]
uh it's too much house uh we got a
now because we're on the sixth floor so
our bathroom sink clogs up that's a big
problem in new york city the higher you
go up because it
stacks on the buildings from like 1932
the pipes haven't probably been replaced
you know maybe once in like this [ __ ]
50s or something so it's just like years
of [ __ ] so we get jammed up so i got to
have [ __ ] drino
on deck and the second it sees i [ __ ]
you got to do it up
i'm doing it probably maybe once a week
i'm doing dreno there's nothing trashier
and nothing to make you feel more like a
man when you do a full w when you're
doing adreno
i treat that like surgery i feel like
i'm i feel like everybody goes in the
bathroom for an hour and a half don't
touch it
don't i'll catch you i'll cover the sink
with it with a with a t-shirt
oh don't even don't even look at the
sink pour that [ __ ] we have this one
stuff put a little behind my ears we
have these
it's a new kitty it's a good company uh
we have these crystals
that we got from the hardware store and
whatever
drano is drano's like you pour it down
and then you pour
scalding hot water or something like
that after a while yeah
this one is cold water oh i don't like
that this one's no [ __ ] around
they're like don't put out water on it
blow the pipes
it's crystals and you hear them in there
cooking
it's like pop rocks and soda basically
this is exactly what it's like you hear
it working
there's this thing now that they're
doing i saw on tick tock the other day
where it's like a foam bomb you put down
in there and it
shoots like a [ __ ] if it's like a
pipe bomb
yeah and like all this [ __ ] comes out of
chair oh really yeah which i kind of
like
i don't want it coming the other way me
either push that down in the sewer to
the fatbergs you know about the fat
burgs and the sewers
that birds fatbergs are like clusters of
like grease and
uh butt wipes and paper towels oh i've
seen i've seen
i've seen i've seen yeah yeah let the
rats handle that
wait you said uh light bulbs at any
point in your life have you had like one
of those
chandelier like ceiling fans that holds
like three lights and like
you're down but you're down to one
because the other two are in the it's in
the living room it's in the bathroom if
you're ever
moving a light bulb from room to room
that's already in a fixture that is a
tough look yeah it's not good it's not
good especially in new york you can just
go buy a [ __ ] you can buy one light
bulb which i like about new york yeah we
got one of them they open up the box
take it
it's great that's when you're real
hemmed up
trash uh speaking of bathrooms this is
from chris did
anyone did you or anyone in your family
ever have an ocean-themed bathroom
oh yeah ocean my cousins had an
ocean-themed living room i think
please tell me they lived in aruba no
there was like there was like seashells
on the wallpaper it was nice it was real
nice
we actually have one of the lamps in my
bedroom now it's a huge lighthouse it's
[ __ ]
classy no real nice we had it down the
shore
my whole the everybody's got it down the
shore i know but this was we had like a
light
the the light and the light and the
living were in the bed in the
sorry in the bedroom it was like two
single beds like two twin beds and the
light between that was like
a three foot lighthouse that stood on
there it was like a proper
like made of wood like it there was like
seventeen thousand lighthouses in this
[ __ ]
apartment yeah i'm not a fan of that
[ __ ] no i don't i don't like the way
um just give me a regular house i know
i'm at the beach i'm looking out the
window i don't like the way beach houses
are
decorated sometimes especially renters
the ones that you rent when you were a
kid
we that's what we did i didn't like it
yeah like [ __ ] crab [ __ ] nets and
[ __ ] like that like get the [ __ ]
you get tangled in it yeah what is this
long john silver's
trying to [ __ ] have a vacation crab
shack you ever been to a joe's crab
shack there
never been a joe's no never been to
joe's there's one i drive by on route 1
it's closed now but that's
not talking about the one down in miami
huh joe's
that's joe's stone crab i'm sorry yeah
no this is just joe's crab shack they
were advertising a bunch although i
never been
never been it's a tough look those uh
corporate seafood
i feel like they probably do pretty good
though i don't know i've never been to a
red lobster either i wouldn't say
anything's fresh
you don't think but they're moving
quality though that's that they're
moving quantity that's
kind of the one thing i think they got
working for maybe they're moving like
[ __ ] they're moving units it ain't
sitting there for a couple of days
i mean it's a burning turn yeah somebody
think all red lobsters are packed 24
7 all the time they have down time i
know bad days but i'm still saying
they're selling more than [ __ ]
mom and pops [ __ ] they're ordering
more too
got the freezers probably stacked with
them i don't think so i don't know
though what do i know i'm just some
[ __ ] poor schmuck you know what you
know what i do know what do you know
guaranteed we have multiple listeners
who have worked at
red lobster just gonna say that who can
[ __ ] tip us to what's going on back
there hit us
let us know baby do the lobsters come in
fresh are they frozen are they already
cooked
that's what i'd like to know they
already read they drive themselves
and bonus points if you worked at a red
lobster in like iowa
oh yeah what's going on there just
hamburger
coming under i'm not doing that
hamburger painted red
which i've said this before i'm a crab
guy i i i said that this weekend
i'm a crab over lobster all day long i
don't know if it's the blue
i don't know if it's the blue collarness
in my fan like 40 coors lights in you
they were looking um i just don't know
i just prefer it and i feel like a
[ __ ] snob when i'm eating
lobster i feel like they know i don't
belong
you know what i mean the lobsters no the
people around me i don't want this guy
this guy's a jerk off this [ __ ] big
four-headed [ __ ]
with a little bit of class yeah uh
trying to eat my eyeballs
i don't know uh
all right let's see there's a couple hot
ones we got a couple of hotties
um this is from philip with an f um did
anyone in your family or does anyone in
your family or you
eat things past the expiration date or
borderline how are you with borderline
food
that's a great question um the foleys
are many things
garbage okay rich is not one of them
[Laughter]
the one thing my mom is always extra
extra cautious with mm-hmm it goes quick
yeah like if we have let's say we had
coleslaw one night
the next day it's gone okay well that's
your last
is a little different it's not there's
not an asset coleslaw
never had anything that was pre-export
or post-expiration date was served at
the foley household unless it was frozen
yeah those birds freeze a lot everything
i know it's
crazy yeah i mean we don't walk it every
day before they went to work something
would get put out for dinner
um there'd be something wrapped up in a
paper towel in the sink
like i said i was just home and my mom
was down the shore so it was me and my
wife in the house and
uh my wife's like oh is this chicken
can you ask your mama if this chicken in
here is good so i text my mom it was
like
chicken breast or like it kind of looked
like yeah it was like chicken breast was
it cooked it was cooked yeah yeah yeah
a tuppy i don't know what it was in i
didn't see it she just said can you ask
me
i might have been in a bag like a
plastic bag brown bag
wrapped up in newspaper yeah oh i love
walking in it
so it was like fresh it was like grilled
chicken or something she goes can you
ask your mom if this is good so i text
my mom hey is the chicken in the fridge
good and she goes
no like exclamation point but this is
how jesus
she goes not for us it's for
it's not good for you it's good for your
stepdad
because he plays by his own rules she's
going
he'll eat whatever he's like a garbage
disposal so she's like he'll eat it
but you shouldn't eat it wow yeah yeah
i'm surprised the piece keeps it in
there even that long it doesn't just put
the kibosh on it for everybody
he's my mom he plays by his own rules so
it's like he'll be like what happened to
the chicken
i think she just knows at this point
just leave the [ __ ] chicken if he
eats it he eats if he gets sick he gets
sick
that's so garbage yeah for leftovers she
said
how that's the rules we play by no it's
not good for us but for this one guy can
eat it yeah
weren't there cutlets in here yeah from
[ __ ]
from the 80s that's a good are you
garbage question have you ever got food
poisoning at your house
i feel like i live with food at the rate
my bowel movements are liquid
something's happening
and it has been for 20 years not at the
foleys i'll say
that right now this broad's got i've
been on the planet 45 years
45 years not one person food poisoning
ever
oh yeah no i was being i was kind of
joking but
yeah sure said he had the runs
yeah i'm just saying that was more about
my diet altogether
yeah yeah i apologize it's okay
i i wasn't taking shots at patty i
didn't think you were
what would you what what rating like
restaurant restaurant
rating would you give your kitchen like
abc
my kitchen at home or my parents i think
it's too mean to do parents
my mom gets an a yeah my mom gets an a i
close my place down c minus
i i would need an inspector who plays
ball for sure yeah
no [ __ ] somebody on the take give him a
envelope going out the door the fruit
flies alone would close us down
yeah we're good with it sometimes we
just let it go like sometimes it just
gets away from it let it rise yeah yeah
yeah
great part about being an adult sure
that's gonna get that happy then you
clean it again
that voting you know whatever
sometimes you don't have to do the
dishes
i didn't mean to make it weird with the
uh with the food poisoning thing no it's
just
[ __ ] um it's fine
thank you you don't need to apologize i
wanna apologize i was just like yeah i
get diarrhea all the time you're like
nothing
not 45 years not once did my mom ever do
anything wrong ever
i get like that sometimes as you know oh
man
sometimes yeah sometimes you go down
fight i feel like the more attention you
draw to it the worse it gets i don't
know
i love my man i don't know where we're
going here see what this next question
is like
do you love your parents you should have
a [ __ ] i'll kill you
you know what i wanted to ask you were
you ever a pallbearer as a kid
[Laughter]
because i feel like i was too many times
yeah well they were like this one's
sturdy get him
um not not a feeling kid
that defined you as garbage if you were
a ball bearer
if you were like 13 14 carrying someone
out
trash it's a tough luck that means it
means there was a means it was an
accident or a tragedy
i remember being a pup you're not
carrying your pop-up out when you're 13.
i remember like cousins or like you know
like
like older cousins that like you called
uncle
i remember [ __ ] bringing a few of
them to the promised land
really as like as like a 13 14 year old
kid
and they're getting like whacked out by
an uncle you know what i mean like to
the point where i knew it
i like i knew the drill i don't need the
guys at the [ __ ] funeral home to tell
me what to do if i can
stand inside pull it out i've only done
it a handful of times i think
uh hopefully you'll move up move a
casket up a staircase like a couch
you're like an eastern european you got
it strapped on your back
hey foley hey henry the elevator's over
here i don't need a witnesses
what do you guys got a matters in there
all right i can move that one
i'll take this one myself boys why don't
you guys go catch a smoke
by the mausoleum
you get one of those you gotta have kids
to get those
no probably not get one of those and
they're like james dean i had to do the
shirt i had to do somebody uh got
cremated and i had to like the six of us
like fake what like you pushed it
we had to do that which is like real
weird what's it on
it's on like a you know a serving tray
not a servant
that's a bad luck it's on like a [ __ ]
you take the top off marty
who's got a lighter i gotta like the
sternus
uncle denny is served
uh this past weekend uh oh god this is
gonna get dark
i saw we were going down the cremation
lane i'm like this is tough
t was like dish weekend i cremated
somebody
i didn't not
sure and they threw holy water and i was
like come on put a coaster down man
sustain
lacquer on this thing
oh jesus um that in the same vein
of ever being uh [ __ ] paul bear's a
kid is funny this has ever been to your
parents wedding which we've talked about
i have
i've been to my dad's wedding yeah tough
last man yeah yeah it's real
it's not classy it's not a classy thing
i would say it's 50
50 that one of those people
aren't your real parent but that does
that make sense
that's more logical than it'd be weird
if your parents if you were there and
your parents were getting married
i feel like i know somebody who had a
kid well why weren't they together to
begin with they were together but they
just didn't get married until after
they had the kid that's a little creepy
that's a little that's more suspect than
a second marriage
i don't know that's kind of nice no it's
not how about this
i knew a kid whose parents got divorced
they both got step
parents they got married those divorced
the original parents got back together
and then the step parents got married
what
that's a real sophie's choice he lives
on general hospital yeah what the [ __ ]
lincoln to north carolina god damn
that's a [ __ ]
maybe we should screw that's weird
i've never had any there's a [ __ ] fly
in here that i'm pretty sure came out of
your [ __ ] armpit
no but i had a spider in my car last
week that scared the [ __ ] he might as
well had a gun
[Laughter]
where's the mcdonald's fan oh dude i
looked over a little
fat one dude like fat had a little
purple on him his [ __ ] eyes were just
mugging me
and i was like what are you doing i
[ __ ] pushed him out the window
rolled the window up that was last turn
around he's driving the car
listen that was last week we had to go
to my aunt's funeral we were in
pennsylvania
two days ago we pull up to the cemetery
i look out it's a ball bearer
i look outside the window my
girlfriend's like oh my god there's a
spider out there i'm like that's him
he's been in my car dude there's no way
this was a different spider he looked
he could have been on peyote or
something no he was in the car
and he wanted money and he wanted the
goods he was like are you my uber
are you here for henry it scared the
[ __ ] out of me um
how do we start talking about spiders i
don't know the fly that came out of your
armpit oh yeah there's flies in here
that's like an omen
oh yeah that you smell we're gonna get
out of this month yeah
i gotta june first baby here we go okay
my patreon start processing some of
those [ __ ] couple of things start
falling through
um let's see here
this one this is from haywood jablomi
uh don't think that's his government
name
i like it and this is something i've
never heard of
uh if i were to say it was good
yeah hayward's a great name it's a real
name right
hayward like yeah haywood yeah johnson
sure
[Applause]
it's a good piece of business you kids
out there i know what they're doing
um if i were to say
what is it i've never heard of this do
you understand do you know what rotten
ronnie's is
rotten ronnie's rotten rotties what's a
rotten rhyme you know rotten ronnie's
no i can't get over here
real high bruh stuff we're doing over
here um
rotten ronnie's is a nickname for
mcdonald's
oh okay rotten ronnie's yeah i could see
it pretty good i never heard of that
sure ronald ronnie rotten ronnie's a
little slanderous against a greater than
that
uh what's the person's question ever
swipe milk crates from the back of a
rotten ronnie's
wawa we used to take them from wawa for
skating you would like try to ollie them
or like you know we use them or like
in the woods when we go smoke weed or
build a fort or whatever we
took a lot of milk crates stolen a lot
of milk crates in my life
never would think in a million years to
go look at a [ __ ] rotten ronnie's
what the [ __ ] was going on in your town
i don't know that's where your main
supply of milk was coming through
that's a tough look yeah you go to an
orbeez like a gentleman
shout out to our love of milk crate let
me tell you that right now
records this that anything
you ran after you ran out of examples
and you don't have a record player love
milk crates
records other things more stuff
miscellaneous things
whatever yeah you have yet to name one
more noun
uh baseball cards baseballs
what are you a pitching coach
baseball dude
generic sports equipment
other things other things you find under
your bed
toys transformers could be one
skateboards
baseball myths skateboards don't fit in
oh my god you are another kind of stupid
dude
[Laughter]
i used to i had a couple we used to put
them in there
i've seen djs with [ __ ] with
sensitive
the sense of humor is usually a good
signifier of intelligence
you're the perfect amount of dumb and
funny it's crazy
it's so crazy
i don't know that's supposed to mean i'm
saying you're very funny
but also very dumb i put stuff in there
it hurts
you don't have them in your apartment
now no i
yeah from a bakery or something like
that not a [ __ ]
rotten ronnie's um oh you don't need to
eat there sir
i'll tell you that right now you do yeah
all right this one's from dylan
company built this country have you ever
attended a car race at a dirt track
raceway
this falls more into me we were i was a
racetrack kid going up
unfortunately you're a low-level
racetrack kid that's not like
you were out [ __ ] in the main lawn at
talladega no we were
hanging out with [ __ ] junior's wife
yeah we were [ __ ] you were in some
legit hole in the middle of pennsylvania
flemington new jersey even better
but uh my stepdad used to race cars and
it was exciting to watch him but i was
the main attraction the big thing i
would get buddies to come with me and
the big selling point was the [ __ ]
durb was the
smash em up derby why that open for them
that that's the closer he
attracts the tracks mayhem after that oh
[ __ ] so it was an actual
race it wasn't like a square where you
just [ __ ] cram into each other
this was an actual race so there was
some [ __ ] you could like slam into
each other oh dude they would just drop
like a dead car in the middle
they would first of all they would soap
up the track with suds they would they
had
like a [ __ ] like a water tank and
then they would actually do
like races on there afterwards that
seems dangerous yeah so you want to
[ __ ] smash them up baby that's no i'm
saying like
your stepdad did real real racist yes
and then the last one was the smash em
up derby
you think even just putting soap on that
track it wouldn't come off for the next
race well i mean this is
this isn't up to nascar [ __ ] i mean
they're trying to get asses in the seats
here okay
this is a [ __ ] it's you know i mean
they got the oakridge
yeah rusty wallace isn't coming in on
the weekend they they need who they need
[ __ ] they need to sell some
merchandise patrick here yet yeah so
they would soap up the [ __ ] and there
would be
some [ __ ] hillbilly some redneck with
a [ __ ]
like a fire with like a thing of palm
olive or no but
it really suds this [ __ ] course up
and
it was a proper [ __ ] track suds did
up and they would drop like
dead caught like you know abandoned cars
so you'd have to [ __ ]
maneuver around them and these [ __ ]
tanks would come out already causing
accidents
yes i was a [ __ ]
i was right up in turn one screaming
hooting and hollering
oh as you imagined that'd be dangerous
for the crowd or something it would dude
it was the 90 i mean
somebody nobody gave a [ __ ] about
somebody got bumped off out there
oh yeah somebody got back with a piece
of funnel cake in their mouth yeah yeah
yeah caught a fire stone in the head
yeah i think i don't think it's open
anymore
um but i would totally like [ __ ]
gillis and six in those dudes they go
out to like central pennsylvania do the
dirt track
oh yeah i think they called like quarter
midgets with like the big [ __ ] wing
on the top uh-huh that's a
dude that and that [ __ ] case of coors
light or something that's a good [ __ ]
time i
want to go to a monster truck show to be
honest with you i'll go let's do it
we're definitely going to go yeah we
have to we got to find out what they are
though that's the only thing
they doing wildwood gravediggers on the
beach we can go down there
that's crazy yeah i think i can meet him
[Music]
is it the same driver no there's
multiple trucks
oh really yeah he's not taking that down
the expressway
i mean there's multiple gravedigger
trucks
it's a national brand oh it's not just
one car
i would argue there's i mean we can like
bigfoot's not bigfoot was the best
classic blue [ __ ] pickup
nice how many gravediggers are there
how many how's the first thing that pops
up 41 gravediggers 41 gravediggers yeah
oh built ripped off seven trucks
currently competing
yeah it's a [ __ ] circle like a team
well you're not going further you're
going for the truck you're not going for
the driver so
someone's in akron ohio at one and
another one's in phoenix
you're telling me gravedigger's like
blue man group yes
yes that just like crushed a dream i
didn't even know i respected yeah no
[ __ ] so how many as google how many
bigfoots there are
there's only one bigfoot i guarantee it
no way it's the same [ __ ] model
you think that bigfoot people just
google it right you think the bigfoot
people
radar you think the bigfoot people were
looking around going these gravedigger
guys are making seven times the money is
me
do you get it oh yeah am i in the van no
from mash
radar o'reilly how many
what is it grave diggers got chuckled as
a kid
how many gravediggers are there is that
what i am no gravediggers bigfoot
i'm gonna get that 90s gravedigger [ __ ]
go 80s
bigfoot well there's many theories that
there might be apparently sasquatch
yeah they're currently five competing
bigfoot
with six full-time drivers and two
fill-ins
20 trucks have been made since the debut
in 1975.
okay okay i'd love to know what that
filling does on the side
something shifty know what tires are
using over there on the big on the
bigfoot
good years fire stones good years are
for bozos okay
i got firestones you got firestone's on
the latitude
a latitude with the attitude aren't you
take a run of that [ __ ] gravedigger
any day
scooter underneath him hit him in the
balls who do you think would win in a
dirt track race between three of us
in a in our car you don't have a license
so you're out you don't need one
um i probably would he's a horrible
driver
hold on are we in cars that we don't
care about yes
oh come on i mean being that he
proper stops at green lights i don't
think you're going to
you're not a good rubber hits the road
baldy
i ain't gonna be worried about that i
know for a fact
and you're a legacy too imagine me
beating you in front of your stepdad
oh he'd be pissed junior he'd take
junior away from you
i know for a fact i show up in his car
he still got him smoke
you don't even know where the gas pedal
is yeah i've driven
what makes you think that you would beat
us because i'm naturally good at [ __ ]
like that
now if you want to get real trashy had a
go-kart growing up
was big big into go-karts we would go to
ocean city merrill it was like we like
it was like a thing well my cousin had
one oh get out of this guy
i'm putting my money on kippy yeah
shakespeare thunder you know what i mean
rubbing is racing
[ __ ] trade and paint if you have
access to a tracker yeah and you're
willing to let me on it without a
license
i mean what would we erase each other or
do times like qualified times
if someone had okay i'm putting it out
there no indie cars i got used both no
way he wouldn't even fit in it sitting
on top
listen this is going out to you know a
lot of people
tens of thousands of people if somebody
has access to a [ __ ] dirt track
anywhere in the country
we'll [ __ ] come out and we'll do and
we gotta use your car
we gotta use all they're not gonna let
us use your there yeah you can rent this
[ __ ]
it's like yeah these hillbillies don't
let us do anything
cash talks um well we'll figure we'll do
like a qualify we'll do
right well you're not gonna fit in a
[ __ ] race car i'll get in there
you barely fit in your jeep
all right no come back for that
in the middle of a weight loss challenge
um and bell's going to tow right after
this too
yeah he had a [ __ ] you just had like a
bacon egg and cheese before i'm like
it's a weigh-in
i'm eating one one meal a day do they
make seat belt centers for bucket seats
i'll bring them once from the plane
[Laughter]
get my own helmet um if you have some
sort of or any i guess any sort of race
track
there's like they have them in they have
them in [ __ ] in rain jersey we can go
do them they have like the proper
they call it like the autobahn or
something oh they have them it they have
them up at uh ridgefield or
where's levity live i just blacked out
dude
you stumbled over your words a lot more
with that shirt on you're in like you're
you're in
half retirement mode i'm [ __ ]
starving myself me and t-bone have a
weight loss challenge this [ __ ] guy
tells me he lost five pounds in three
days he's grieving by the way which is
cheating
it's all tears that's [ __ ]
i'm over here starving myself [ __ ]
doing coffee and bernie's i'm [ __ ]
wired i'm starving too
um starving you had a croissant and a
bag of chips literally 47 minutes ago
you moved through me
my engine's running these days i'm out
i'm more active
i'm turning and burning talking about
race cars to put a pin in it if you've
got access to it to a racetrack
and are willing to look the other way on
some paperwork
on some driver's license numbers talk to
the boys a couple of floozy track girls
wouldn't kill us either
yeah couple of girls to drop the
handkerchief in the middle
oh yeah that's what i'm talking um
my mom would love to do that really oh
she'd be out there
really showing the goods did that was
was drag racing ever a thing
when you were in high school and stuff
no we used to go down to like essington
avenue
i was all scared of that [ __ ] i never i
thought that [ __ ] was stupid and i never
did that [ __ ] there was this one kid
wayne he's got to be dead
for sure dude next kid this kid
fast to talk about fast and loose wayne
pushed it oh
man he was like he was the kind of guy
you were just like what the [ __ ] is
i i kept him in a d and i ran with some
nefarious characters and this kid was
just like
your radar's up right away yeah we had a
couple of dudes like that and he would
go down racing with my boys
like they would go down with them and
they would like spin out i'm like
nah well it was like fast and furious
dropped when we were in high school so
that was like
that was big people in a parking lot
doing donuts and [ __ ] that stuff was
lame
i tried in my 96 chevy lumina oh god
didn't work
front of chicks yeah strikeout are you
wearing that shirt
i see you guys later i guess that's mean
i don't know how that's supposed to make
me feel
all right let's power through a couple
more here we got a giddy up
this one's from tony p home run of a
question ever swim in public and jean
shorts
i can't say i've ever swam in denim on
purpose maybe falling in a pool getting
thrown in a pool or something but never
on [ __ ] purpose
that was a great time to pull away from
the [ __ ] microphone for 30 seconds
that was
my ears rich and that's throwing people
in the pool
is garbage that was big oh that was
huge yeah huge there was no cell phones
well we had we had high school cell
phones
everybody had their own cell phones you
had to be like oh the big thing was
i had to come up with a way to get the
cell phone out of their pocket
so you'd be like my parents used to do
that to each other
cause they're [ __ ] healed until like
until like my cut they would throw each
other in the pool
i remember the one kid that was like no
fun he would like be like holding onto
the fence or whatever
go break the fence like relax we're
wearing bathing suits
take it easy [ __ ] chuck whatever your
name was
i was always a kid it was only like you
know exalt an auxiliary player he wasn't
on the squad
he always got called up from the miners
remember one time it worked it's a
bigfoot fill in
yeah he's the alternate driver one time
who is
okay god damn dude
you might have to snip a little bit of
that sometimes i think you forget you're
broadcasting
i understand people go you get mad at
henry sometimes i go yeah because i hit
him in the ball and he's over there
eating a ham sandwich
i was thinking of my story which wasn't
very funny
this is about throwing a kid in a
recyclable thing full of glass
we didn't do it but we had him when we
were swinging he was like no
don't do it yeah like what you're saying
freaking out
but it was you know shards of glass that
would have
surely ripped him to shreds it looked
like a wolverine got him
um all right this one's from nicholas a
new patron first question ever install
an aftermarket cup holder in your car
[Laughter]
those are next level trash when you
gotta like hook it into something like
basketball yeah like hooks or something
you know what else is really trashy too
the ashtray that would go in the cup
holder that you would ash in that it
would have did you ever see that no
it was like a it looked like this it
looked like the wawa cup and then this
would be like
a cylinder like a funnel with a hole in
it and you would ash in that and then
put it in
no way the people that had that always
had the [ __ ]
the air the the things on the vents with
the juice in them
the air fresheners hit the bricks
that was for [ __ ] russians or
something i don't know what that was
no way dude you got your car and you had
one
you had [ __ ] cherry sauce blasting at
me you better be an uber driver in
uzbekistan
take a hike with that [ __ ] that [ __ ]
stunk
get me a tree or a [ __ ] i used to
smoke things to kill that stuff
dude i might for a minute my mom had
ones that had fans on them
oh they were yeah the glade plug-ins
it's like this is for your basement
this is for places that have mold and
not the [ __ ] not your air conditioner
you sound like you're selling a jet
engine firing up
yeah febreze i think or somebody did the
little oils and you're like what are we
doing
yeah you know what's the trash it smells
like the [ __ ] janitor's closet you
know what's the trashiest air freshener
it's the old school one and we had it we
were
gone where it's the jelly inside and you
you pull it up and it's like a cone of
jelly you know what i'm talking about
i still tried doing those and my wife
was like
and it eats away at it when those things
dry up
it was like a civil war soldier that was
left out under a tree just like
mummified yeah the gl you twist the cone
and pull it up and they were the things
like i would like reuse it
it was called reuse and i would just
[ __ ] rip it open oh yeah you don't
[ __ ]
you don't work the governor on that you
[ __ ] high and dry baby
man those things got real sad those
smelled like urinal cakes
you walked into your house right away
you're smelling like you were in the
[ __ ]
you were in the john no those things
those things stunk and i thought they
were great i thought i was gonna like
show my wife like look what we got over
here she's like what the
[ __ ] no way are we doing that yeah i
really thought i was like check these
things out
sometimes i don't realize how trashy i
am i think i'm classy
man you had those things when you were a
kid you're like poking at it and playing
with it and [ __ ]
that and the little [ __ ] little dirt
ball did you ever lick it
yeah i mean he was looking as deodorant
i don't believe so only on holidays
july 4th would come around um
it's crazy that that's like a legitimate
question
all bets were awesome oh that apple's in
cine
my mom stills once the fall hits
it's all apples in the center not those
things no candles whatever
you walk into my mom's house you feel
like you're walking in the [ __ ]
season i'll never forget dude shout out
to yankee [ __ ] sugar cookies dude
that thing
we had one in college i felt like i was
a keebler elf dude that thing
was cooking dude [ __ ] yankee candles
forget it those things that put you to
sleep
they're also like 55 cleaning talking
about drifting away those things are
bangers yeah um fantastic all right
let's do one more and this
first of all the name is super funny
because it's something this is from
smarted um
[Music]
and i'm for sure stealing this ever call
getting a bunch of apps for the table
sprinkling the infield that is [ __ ]
uh that's the kind of quality questions
we're looking for around here in hoodies
sprinkle the infield a little bit get a
couple get a couple of [ __ ] apps
that's great sprinkle in the info i've
never heard it referred to as that but
that's fantastic oh yeah
big fan of that walk in sprinkle the
infield
couple of [ __ ] apps for the table
let's get things started real quick
while we're looking over the menu
let's get mussels we'll do one red one
right we'll do the tomato salad
anybody want the clams you want oysters
you want this you want that
bring it we just did i went down it was
my mom's it was it was my mom's birthday
we went out mcgurks horsham and horsham
there's another one yeah okay
um there's a meter central meeting point
but [ __ ] big table
i had like 15 people to talk about
sprinkle in the infield dude yeah it was
like blitzkrieg with appetizers
they were dropping them things every on
the minute some like [ __ ] flatbreads
were going
some [ __ ] fries some of this some of
that little edamame
ooh edamame at my gerks real nice look
at you down there
spending a couple of bucks in it up yeah
all right
gang we love you very much thank you for
everything uh we'll be back next week
uh june 18th atlantic city new jersey
yes
we have an 8 30 show all right they
opened up about 30 more tickets for the
8 30 show
it's gonna go there's not going to be a
10 30 show we want it all combined into
one great
[ __ ] show yeah so there's more
tickets june 18th atlantic city
get on that [ __ ] grab some ticks also
uh
the fourth and final show in chicago is
on tuesday of that week i believe it's
the 22nd
tuesday the 22nd there's a 9pm show
there's still tickets available
available for that get those [ __ ]
ticks asap also
indie baby we're talking indie helium
comedy
helium comedy club wednesday the 23rd
yes get those [ __ ] tickets as well
also people are hitting me up they don't
know what's on sale we have boston on
sale
we have the stress factory in new jersey
on sale we have baltimore
maryland boobies on sale coming to
mcgooby we have cleveland hilarity's on
sale we have columbus on sale
we got providence we got providence on
sale and we're adding a bunch more dates
as well down
we're going to get everywhere people are
hitting me up hey do shows here do shows
here we're going to be doing new york
we're going to be doing philly we're
going to be doing pittsburgh
we're going to be doing texas we're
going to be coming to florida pacific
northwest
everywhere baby west coast we're doing
it so just hang tight we're waiting on
all the restrictions and [ __ ] to change
so we can uh
what so we can what our beaks make it
worth our while you know what i mean
that's right we'll have something out
soon with everything on it and all that
stuff
maybe and real quick real quick i want
to give a big shout out to john
in the facebook group organized a bunch
of people who donated
uh johnny griffin 1500 bucks to the
american cancer society in sam's name so
thank you so much everybody
you guys are rock solid you're absolute
um
fantastic support system we love you we
appreciate you we'll see you next week